monsieur le ministre y a quelques jours
damman département du gard le feu a
consumé 900 hectares en près de 24
heures bordés ac bessèges gagnières
générac ou encore alès n'ont pas été
épargnés aujourd'hui le nombre gardois
s'apprêtent à vivre leur était avec
l'angoissé permanente de ces flammes je
veux rendre ici hommage appuyé aux
sapeurs pompiers mobilisés c'est grâce à
leur bravoure et à la réactivité des
maires concernés qu aucune habitation
n'a été touchée en lien avec le sous
préfet d'arrondissement
reste que ces feux s'ils peuvent être
des drames humains sont toujours un
désastre écologique monsieur le ministre
il faut absolument adapter nos textes à
nos territoires en effet il arrive qu'au
nom de la biodiversité des élus
départementaux ou municipaux ne peuvent
débroussailler les abords des routes
comme il le souhaiterait est ce enfin de
faire et ce afin d'en faire de
véritables coupe feu il faut davantage
laissé des préfets concilier ces deux
objectifs qui je tiens à leur dire ne
sont pas antinomiques surtout nos
communes rurales peuvent s'étendre sur
de nombreux hectares et ses communes
gardoises ne peuvent assumer seul ce
risque qui malheureusement est amené à
simplifier le débroussaillement à un
couteau si important que son utilité
tout comme l'entretien des voies des fc
ou encore les vigies monsieur le
ministre vous en conviendrez les feux
coïncidera romain avec les limites
administratives et cette lutte contre
les incendies doit pouvoir compter sur
le soutien total de l'état allez vous
renforcer les moyens financiers des
collectivités concernées par sa télé à
feu je vous remercie